- [Narrator] This Great
Big Story was made possible
by Wells Fargo, established
1852, re-established 2018.
When it comes to horror movies,
there's an actor who
is so good at his job,
his performances stay with you
like a nightmare you
just can't wake up from,
but trust us, he's a really nice guy.
(sinister music)
- [Interviewer] Could you give us a clap?
- Let's go.
I'm Javier Botet, and I'm an actor.
- [Narrator] And Javier's
been in a lot of movies,
you probably just didn't see him
because, well, he looks quite
different most of the time.
- I feel very comfortable
in monster roles,
I've been in "It," "Mama," "Conjuring 2,"
"Crimson Peak," "Slender Man."
- [Narrator] And let's not forget,
he's been in "The Mummy" and "Alien," too.
- I'm very skinny; I'm two meters tall
and 56 kilograms.
It's not a problem of
eating, 'cause I love to eat;
it's a personal condition;
it's called Marfan Syndrome.
- [Narrator] Javier's career started
when he met a prosthetic
makeup teacher in Madrid.
This led to Javier's first monster role
in the movie, "Beneath Still Waters."
- That was my first makeup,
my first work in a real movie
and, well, after that,
all the makeup artists
start seeing my work and start
proposing me in other roles,
and last year I'd been working
in eight or nine different shows.
- [Narrator] There's gotta be
some behind-the-scenes gossip then?
- Yeah, well, I was in Crimson Peak,
I was out of all the makeup,
and I was the last day
with Guillermo del Toro,
and I see Tom Hiddleston
and I say, "OK, see you,
"it was a pleasure," and
he said, "Who are you?"
So I said, "I was your ex-wives."
"Oh, OK, OK, OK ..."
"Sorry, I didn't recognize you."
- [Narrator] But don't
pigeonhole this guy.
He might be a monster most of the time,
but he's got dramatic range.
- OK, guys, are you ready?
Really love what you do,
'cause it's going to be
a hard and long journey.
Be prepared,
you never know what's gonna happen.
Don't be shy; don't let
the fear paralyze you.
So relax,
you know what I mean?
Woo!
Whew!
(laughing)
If I can ask for something,
I would love to be a big Sith,
I will rule the galaxy.
(lasers firing and humming)
- [Interviewer] That's amazing,
that's amazing, thank you.
- [Javier] Thank you.